[Music]
yeah I mean you are you're saying that
God made a mistake with me so by the way
here's an update we talked a little bit
about you know that Tim Dylan the two to
too lazy to try guy
so here yeah by the way thanks a lot too
late to try because now that [ __ ]
image I already knew what you were
talking about it it burned into my brain
now I don't even associate that with
[ __ ] Jason Alexander anymore oh yeah
it's too late to try and by the way if I
ever see what it really looks like it's
going to be disappointing because in my
head this is what he looks like
I'm going down with my channel and Tim
Dylan and I wanted to wait a few days to
make this video I just figured it out
too lazy to try is just secretly Travis
Brown
because I want to see if him or anybody
from his team would respond to this but
nobody has so far so here we go and I'm
not going to use any footage or audio
from Tim's podcast so there's no way he
could take down this video so I'm sure
most people have heard by now the other
day Tim Dillon did a copyright takedown
on one of my videos and he gave my
channel a strike which is pretty
surprising considering Tim is very
pro-free speech anti-censorship you know
he goes on Joe Rogan he does the whole
circle jerk talking about how bad
censorship is and how big tech companies
are out of control with the platforming
people okay well I'm sorry can you pause
sure sorry uh I hate you I hate to break
it to you uh too lazy to try I'm gonna
let you in on a little secret uh every
human being
is Free Speech until they get pissed off
enough yeah every single one of them
people are getting too soft and too
sensitive nowadays but now it's starting
to look like he's just a grifter and a
massive hypocrite that only can always
Astronaut mean bro always was
yeah exactly like wow you're really just
realizing now that always was bro always
for us honey because he gets a little
criticism from the internet and he does
copyright takedowns and he gives out
strikes like that's what bothers me he's
a stand-up comedian he's a stand-up
comedian yes that's what they all are
they do that they're doing for [ __ ]
years he's showing what frail [ __ ]
they are and how they [ __ ] melt down
at the first moment somebody pushes back
even slightly yeah and immediately
immediately panicked and by the way Tim
Dylan everyone except Louis J Gomez I
will say that everyone Louis J Gomez is
the only one that calls Carl from one of
these boxes and threatens physical harm
on him if he doesn't bad
like this is Brendan shab level stuff
and I've never even had to deal with
this from Brendan and I go a lot harder
on him and age three I make H3 look like
a complete idiot in my videos I talk
about him all the time he's never done
anything even close to this which is
hilarious because Tim was just on a
trees well I mean to be fair too lazy to
try not to you but I mean I would argue
that JJ Stoner has a big Valley claim
against H3 if we're being fair yeah yeah
JJ got a strike because of him he does
this [ __ ] all the time podcast like a
month ago and he's talking about it's
just a [ __ ] Wednesday
which is funny by the way and and JJ
sieven said midgets watch my show man
they think it's funny and it's like yeah
I know anybody with a sense of humor
would get it not deserve to get banned
and how censorship is just the worst
thing ever and you should never try to
censor anybody but now that's a really
good point especially after you went on
H3 we actually played it and Tim Dylan
was talking about we Andrew Tate
remember saying how [ __ ] up it was and
he should be allowed to say what he
wants but now I criticize him a little
bit and he has my video taken down and
now my channel is a strike and if I get
two more I'm de-platformed I'm kicked
off YouTube for good and all my videos
are gone which I don't need that because
I'll be honest too lazy to try
you have given us so much content that
we appreciate it so I'll listen I'll
tell you what man we have a we have a
format on how you fight copyright
strikes I'll just send you the copy
paste okay
there it is oh that doesn't help with
copyright but you know if you move to
rumble we will help so Tim's hardcore
yeah let's do exclusive program it's
called moving to rumble wait wait tell
me more
all right step one you move to rumble
that's it step do you stream and you
make your videos and they pretty much
leave you alone as long as you're not
like [ __ ] being right you know what
we need to do right now is kill some
dudes like as long as you're not doing
that [ __ ] you're fine I don't really
care yeah if you want to just call
people gay fat and stupid on the
internet we'll allow it we're like
perfect
I just grasp me at straws and Dylan also
is all three of those things
[Laughter]
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean if you overact if you
overact people won't realize it you
you're insecure and you don't fit in
yeah I know Tim dude the Elaine
Maxwell's shirt was pretty funny dude
yeah it was really funny when Sam Hunt
when Sam High did it
it's like hey I'm gonna wear this shirt
so that somebody will notice me in a
room with Alex Jones and Joe Rogan
that's a real oh my God he was
peacocking you're right Marshall he was
[ __ ] peacocking
you're not gonna pay any attention to me
in the room today so I'll wear this cool
shirt everybody be like oh dude free
Glade Maxwell that's crazy she's a sex
trafficker dude that's so edgy you know
the problem is the other issue is what
you know why they go after people like
too lazy to try on all these channels
because they unlike us you know we our
names are out there so it doesn't matter
but when you do a copyright like you
know appeal you have to put your your
name in your address like that's part of
the appeal process and they know that a
lot of these people don't want to dox
themselves you know to do it so then
they just eat the strike trying to think
of any excuse me that's one of the
things that's really liberating about
being self-docs yeah
what's your docs I'm like oh no
oh no claim you want to [ __ ] play
games with me man like if you're gonna
just steal my company here's my name
here's my address my phone number and
you know what everybody that like
especially the clip channels are just
like steal [ __ ] and then like change the
titles and stuff like the the channels
who just don't like you they had no
commentary they do nothing so I did a
soft takedown one day like the seven
days like take it down or counter file
and I just I was I was like go ahead
counter file I've got a counter file Mr
hides behind [ __ ] stupid nicknames
they never want to do that
and by the way and by the way but again
that was them literally not that wasn't
just taking clips and adding nothing and
basically putting up episodes we're too
lazy to try is doing his promoting
providing transformative content he
always pauses he talks over it oh yeah
well that's why I made the distinction
it was people that were like uploading
40 minute segments
if somebody uploaded
how many times have I filed a claim
against the channel that's just if I had
to [ __ ] file claims on channels of
[ __ ] on me I wouldn't have time to do
shows anymore yeah so it's like you can
[ __ ] on me but just add something put a
[ __ ] put some tunes behind it talk
some [ __ ] and I'll leave you alone yeah
I know I agree like if I don't I don't
want anybody just taking the entire
episode of the show and just [ __ ]
putting it out there for free that's
[ __ ] and to justify him taking down
my video like his top mod on his
subreddit it's just straight up lying
about my video and claiming I didn't add
anything yeah but everyone read it's
[ __ ] so don't even worry about that
bud commentary to it and it's not
transformative at all which I've never
seen a group of people think they know
everything and be the stupidest people
on the internet that's what Reddit is
right
like in general like they're everyone's
a [ __ ] expert but they always give
this terrible advice you know look
here's a great actually give a great
example watch which is [ __ ] because
I'm sure most of you watched the video
it had commentary in it yes and if you
did any of my other videos I think
there's about 200 now I think just two
of them I don't have any commentary
because they're just like curb meme
videos but everyone every other one just
click on it you'll hear commentary and
this is so ironic too because the audio
that I used in my video from Tim
Dillon's podcast is still all over
YouTube and without commentary and even
longer I think maybe I used like a
minute this is an eight minute yeah but
you were but see you yeah that's even
more egregious because now you can't
even hide behind the like I'm trying to
protect my you know intellectual
property now it's just like now you're
being petty you're be you're being
absolutely shitty and and honestly Tim
Dylan is a petty guy it's like he said
he's a [ __ ] guy yeah I know he's not a
good guy a clip with no commentary at
all so it sounds like if I uploaded it
without commentary it would still be up
and it wouldn't have been taken down so
these people are so confused they're
just doing whatever they can to try to
make Tim don't look good but it doesn't
seem like it's working also the YouTube
channel joke world he has the same Clips
I used yeah I brought that up the other
day in his and his videos still up his
channel is seven times bigger than mine
his video had more views he used the
same clips and it's still up Tim Dillon
had no problem with that so it's very
clear this is not about me using his
content and the clips we used were yes
because Joker wasn't making fun of him
as much as you were that's all it is
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
Behavior insecure [ __ ] Ben Pitts Ben
pixels did it to us but well more
specifically Brendan chop but Penn picks
Ben pixels did it to us when we were
when we were playing stuff happens all
the [ __ ] time Stuttering John dinner
to us
felt entertainment did it to us
how'd that work
too lazy you could fight this and you
could win this you could easily fight
this and you could easily win this and
rub it in his stupid face and you should
from a patreon episode literally the
only the only
file it properly but you have to put
your name and address on there but I
mean [ __ ] it this guy [ __ ] doxes you
then you've got something then he's
[ __ ]
yeah exactly that's still fair use
people are acting like if it's behind a
paywall then you can't talk about it but
that's not true at all people react to
paywall content all the time correct
movies TV shows stand-up specials I mean
it's literally a perk of being in our
locals and patreon and so yeah I hope
that doesn't stop
please God don't oh or just patreon
content I mean I'm not uploading the
whole thing I uploaded like a minute
minute and a half in the middle of a
video where I'm talking about it people
are acting like I just took this whole
episode and uploaded to YouTube which I
think if I did it'd probably still be up
that's the crazy part about it like
twitch streamers they'll react to a full
movie and this is all because he didn't
want to know the Ben Avery thing and all
the fighting that they had and honestly
I don't really care about that stuff but
now I want to know what is it like what
was the big deal about this why what are
you hiding here bud
and the movie company that produced the
movie doesn't do anything about it most
the time they're not even Petty enough
to try to do anything to take down their
video or strike if Tim like really had a
problem with me reacting to his patreon
content and that was a big problem for
him which it isn't because it's
obviously still all over YouTube but if
it was he could have easily just claimed
the audio from my video and then my
video would have been taken down but I
wouldn't have been muted he's 100 right
that's another you know what I gave all
the other options but I also forgot
about that option you could just claim
the audio because it was a podcast right
and then it would get muted you wouldn't
get a strike he wouldn't he wouldn't get
a strike yeah no again this was absolute
I'll [ __ ] show this guy exactly I'll
show this little piece of [ __ ] you want
to [ __ ] play games with me that's
what this was you know what's gonna
happen because this is funny on your
little [ __ ] Channel I'm sure that's
what he's saying now you're not gonna
make money on your little [ __ ]
channel you [ __ ] nobody you zero yeah
that's right I'm Tim Dillon he [ __ ] I
moved to Austin for two months and then
[ __ ] got stuck there because I didn't
want to be there anymore yeah because I
don't know it's not a vibrant gazing
like La I I am yeah cause it turns out I
like La more because I'm obsessed with
Hollywood pedophilia and I come off
sometimes like a guy who uh you know
protests a little bit too much
he does protest too much
yeah he does I'm serious like all right
yeah but you want to live in Los Angeles
and be a part of Hollywood too but
you're obsessed with the pedophilia
angle okay it seems weird I get it and
it's like if you joined if you like if
you joined a cartel and you like I just
really like killing people so I don't
even care about the money and the
cocaine but I think it's just hilarious
to me because it's like these people are
such fun you said at the beginning
they're all liked it but these people
are [ __ ] what a phony you're [ __ ]
phony just like the [ __ ] rest of them
and what bothers me is that you never
have the balls to go after bigger chin
go on I [ __ ] I dare you
[ __ ] oh well I'll clip it come after
we'll fight you that's right I [ __ ]
dare you to go after Carl from horse I
dare you that piece of [ __ ] dare you in
fact Tim he's been saying you know I
[ __ ] I think Jim Dillon's not even
really gay he said talking cash money he
told me that dare you to go after him
yeah so Carl said play every Tim Dillon
paywall episode without commentary Every
Day Live stream it for myself I'd go
after college go ahead tough guy he said
I dare you what are you gonna do
I don't know man I wouldn't I look me
hey merch me personally I wouldn't take
that
no no not for me not from that [ __ ] no
way uh TP yeah
Carl whp on Twitter go ahead sue him
[Laughter]
I love just starting more [ __ ] for poor
Carl all the time
I know I like Carl Carl rules and it
would have let me remove the audio which
he's got enough problems with [ __ ]
stutter and John and all his fake
lawsuits yeah [ __ ] it like serious one
that was already dropped it's so funny
bro I'm doing I would have done
making fun of me
you literally made your career getting
made fun of for a stutter now we're not
allowed to make fun of you yeah he's no
he's a nice guy you know he he's helping
cancer victims merge you idiot
Stuttering John angel investor
Stuttering John angel investor
[Laughter]
and left the video up it wasn't that
important to the video I did that a few
times with Brandon Schaub but Brennan
Schaub hasn't even steeped this a lot
with my channel it's crazy Tim went for
the jugular here and he just yeah to be
fair Ben pixels never gave us a strike
but pixels just blocked the video
I think Brendan didn't do it to you is
because he's learning his lesson yeah
he's already stepped in enough shift
piles I feel like Brendan would have
done this to you a year ago if he didn't
step into that whole swing of YouTuber
thing and all that other crowd he kind
of [ __ ] himself
yeah bro hey Tom Tom public opinion bro
get two more of my Channel's gone and
I'm just off of YouTube so I saw
somebody actually posted the community
post that I made on here to Tim Dillon
sub and whoever did that I really
appreciate it I'm glad some people
understand what's going on here and
actually for the most part I think most
these comments supported me so that's
really good to see but of course that
moderator that I was talking about
earlier you know what's so funny
his original video with the Tim Dylan
when had a couple thousand views right
this video now because it's the
Streisand Effect and Tim Dillon should
know that
this that this video 31 000 views
you see what happens
oh no no this is gonna get a lot of
views because this is what happens you
[ __ ] [ __ ] now the argument could be
made this is the problem with [ __ ]
timidilities I gay guy clubs
who cares who cares about Tiff Dillon uh